wie lange ist es her dass du mal
Minecraft durchgespielt hast vor ein
Jahr wurdest du ja aktuell zutrauen ist
noch selber so aus dem Kopf
hinzubekommen in der neuesten Version
[Musik]
nee
ich würde an deiner Stelle jetzt mach
ich mal noch wildspitzhacke dich mal
runter und Bau erstmal ein paar
Steinzeit bekommen
[Musik]
Tiere Minecraft aber gut muss ich jetzt
durch
wir können das auch Fleisch ausspielen
eigentlich ich will ja ja lass Fleisch
los nur wenige Minuten später so lange
dauern alles ja also wenn du sagst genau
ich überlege gerade
Fleisch essen sollten was soll ich denn
ins Kinder stellen
das bin ich ja sieht man trägst du immer
so ein lila T-Shirt ne hey findest du
jetzt mal ehrlich ist schon gut aus oder
ich meine dass du mir gerade ein paar
Styling Tipps geben wolltest also
ja so sitzen damit alles schön
abgeschnürt ist du gibst in ein Hit
läufst sofort weg und dann gehst du zum
Beispiel hier an den Spot hin und baut
sich einfach vier Blöcke hoch
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bist du da ganz hinten in den Wald
gegangen
siehst du diese Kirche so da bist du
okay dann nee ich bin nicht bei der
Kirche aber von der Kirche siehst du
mich so irgendwann hat er aber keine
Trades mehr oder genau dann müsste der
halt wieder arbeiten und wenn er sich
irgendwann nicht mehr arbeitet also wenn
er sich nicht mehr aktualisiert dann
macht er das am nächsten Tag um 12 Uhr
12 Uhr
an der Sonne also du kannst jetzt sehen
was wir jetzt für eine Uhrzeit ja die
Sonne steht im Westen hier geht es
langsam runter sitzt so langsam später
Nachmittag so 17 Uhr
Fußball so mäßig bist ja doch sehr
intensiv sogar sehr intensiv
[Musik]
es ist schon ein sehr schöner
Traditionsverein der okay schon
Tradition gute wie auch schlechte Zeiten
gemacht und viele schlechte oh okay wenn
du sagst viele schlechte dann sowas in
die Richtung Kaiserslautern oder HSV
würde ich sagen schwarz weiß blau nur
das und ja ganz tief
aber
[Musik]
hier einfach mal hier rein oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
oh nein du wolltest mit mir ohne sterben
machen
komm dann machen wir jetzt aber auch mit
Essen dann machen wir jetzt wirklich auf
Speed Speed run lass mal zeitgleich uns
vor einem Baum stellen
[Musik]
jeder stellt sich so vor einem Baum
hatte jeder hier in jeder mit so eine
Birke
schneller die steinsam hat okay okay 3 2
1 los
[Musik]
hä wie was hast du jetzt
bitte Schwert Schaufel Harke Aktien und
ich habe eine Spitzhacke
[Musik]
ja das ist also
hä
okay ich gebe dir gleich den einmal dann
machst du auch noch ein Portal dann will
ich mal sehen wie schnell du das machst
sag mal was machst du da dicker
Portal ist fertig
den Sprung
[Musik]
wie viel nuggetasten 20er Pack habe ich
geholt beim Angebot
hingesetzt damit ich mich hier nicht
runterfallen ich hatte mich gerade
einfach so ein Schutz für dumme hier für
mich sind Geländer
nicht
ihr schaltet jetzt besser
[Musik]
also du kannst Wasser auch nicht
ausschalten
Minecraft
[Musik]
sein können bei mir brennt ich melde
dich dann gleich zurück ich bin schon
offline
ach so wann bist du denn wieder online
dann geh doch mal online
nein Basti du hast mal varo gewonnen ich
habe das letzte Mal gewonnen ja krass
wir sind da ne ja wir sind da wollen wir
spielen wer den anderen als ersten
okay
[Musik]
schon essen immer aufpassen mit den lila
Partikel diggern wie gesagt das ist ein
Dragon spread da stirbst du drin ja
[Musik]
okay wunderbar
okay pass auf du musst es gleich wieder
in die Mitte fliegt gehst Du hier so hin
und dort wo sein Kopf ist jetzt nichts
machen oh jetzt ist halt hier ein
bisschen dort wo sein Kopf ist zu da
ziehst du ein Bett und dann ein Block
aber davor ansonsten tötest du dich
damit so kannst du killen
okay also wenn seinen Kopf da ist dann
ziehe ich ihn genauso wie du es gerade
gemacht hast genau jetzt geht er oder in
die mit in die Mitte du musst jetzt an
okay
warte warte noch
genau
stehst
du schwer stark
geil einfach
vorbeikommen okay
boah echt nicht so schlecht
[Musik]
ja also
so schlecht war es jetzt ehrlich nicht
habe daneben ist auch vorbei meinst du
HSV oder was
sagen können ich bin auch kein fertig
war heute geil 30 der beste der neunte
das ist mein liebling ich hätte einfach
machen
ich habe gar nicht mehr daran gedacht
dass ich ja sterben könnte ich wollte
einfach nur schnell eine Treppe bauen
und dann da rein jumpen aber wir haben
es ja geschafft ja sicher haben wir den
Drachen halt getötet ne also man könnte
jetzt wenn man sehr streng ist halt
schon sagen es geht darum halt es ne
durch das Portal zu gehen aber ja was
war ja also ein paar Items von mir sind
ins Portal gefallen ja eben also ein
Teil von mir hat es geschafft dann bin
ich zufrieden wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann schaut gern mal bei Basti vorbei
und du sollst mir gerade ein Video
aufgenommen
lassen wir auf jeden Fall ein Like da
Leute
[Musik]